So this is my vow all gods will die
this ends here and now
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is my
thor love and thunder video why thanos didn't
use eternity to kill half the universe instead
of the infinity gauntlet because it seems like
a pretty big shortcut the movie itself was already
kind of a speed run version of the infinity saga
get rid of a giant group of beings in one
fell swoop if you're brand new to the channel
i do marvel videos every week marvel comic con is
happening next week they're going to be dropping a
bunch of big trailers like black panther 2 trailer
some of the big disney plus series i'll be doing
videos for everything so be sure to subscribe
to get all those videos and careful for spoilers
for thor love and thunder if you haven't seen the
movie yet because we'll be talking about the whole
plot but in the movie gorr's big plan is right
out of the comics he declares war on the mcu gods
after learning about the necro sword and choosing
him as his next champion they never fully explain
the voices coming to him from the necro sword in
the movie but i will do a separate video about
that pretty soon i'm just waiting a little bit
longer because a lot of times marvel will explain
extra little details like that right after the
movie comes out like a bunch of the deadpool
deleted scenes that were supposed to be in doctor
strange too we literally just learned about that
in the past week talk about maximum effort don't
worry i will do a separate video about that soon
but gorr essentially does the same thing that
thanos did only for the gods in the mcu just
single universe it's not meant to be a multiverse
movie it's just taking place in the 616 marvel
cinematic universe but he's balancing the universe
getting rid of all the gods because the majority
of all gods are terrible people as we saw during
the moon knight series kanchu pretty terrible god
and like after avengers infinity war and avengers
end game came out they had all the thanos was
right memes they even included that during the
hawkeye series like the thanos was right meme in
the bathroom they actually did that meme after the
gorr arc and used it in the mighty thor storyline
which was a completely separate comic book
arc where jane foster got the hammer like they
actually canonized gorr was right eventually gorr
learns about a shortcut a way to accomplish his
goal killing all the gods in one fell swoop his
infinity gauntlet level upgrade in the comics that
was a bomb designed by a person called shadrach
the god of bombs that could kill all gods at the
same time they just called it the god bomb in
the movie that's what they use the cosmic entity
eternity for there's some similarities between
the comic book version and the movie version but
the way they use eternity in the mcu is that he's
like a one time only first person gets the prize
wish granting genie saying that gorr plans to be
the first person to make it to actual eternity
and wish that the gods didn't exist killing all
them instantly both in the movie and in the comics
eternity is meant to be the living embodiment
of the entire universe as a cosmic entity it
basically represents an entire idea like it's the
consciousness of everything that exists in the 616
marvel universe there's a version for every single
universe in the multiverse so like the version of
eternity in the 838 illuminati universe would
be different from the mcu version that we see
in the movie and if gorr were able to travel the
multiverse to the 838 universe he couldn't wish
that that version of eternity kill all the six
one six universe gods within their own universes
eternity is basically omnipotent they have
control over all reality time and space
but just in the universe where they exist so
technically they could grant your wish as long
as it pertained to something in the universe where
they exist but like it couldn't kill the living
tribunal for instance because the living tribunal
is supposed to be a multiverse being there's only
one for the entire multiverse and thus it's meant
to be a little bit more powerful than eternity
there are beings that are more powerful than the
living tribunal though like the beyonders for
example are more powerful than the living tribunal
because they exist outside the normal multiverse
so like the most powerful thing ever inside the
entire multiverse would be like the one above
all the one true god of the entire multiverse but
that's so powerful that you rarely see them use
that in stories like even when cosmic entities
themselves like the most powerful cosmic beings
inside the multiverse go to war with each other
even then the one above all usually doesn't get
involved i don't think we'll ever see a version
of that inside any of the mcu disney plus series
or any of the mcu movies so if eternity is meant
to be so powerful and there's only one eternity
inside the 616 universe why didn't thanos use it
to accomplish his goal instead of going around
assembling six different infinity stones using
way more considerable effort like it took him
a long time and a lot of effort to assemble all
those infinity stones into the infinity gauntlet
one of the funny things in the comics if you read
the thanos infinity gauntlet storyline like the
classic version that they based infinity war in
avengers endgame on is that thanos actually does
use the infinity gauntlet to fight a version
of eternity that's how powerful the infinity
gauntlet is that it's able to withstand the power
of eternity in the movie they explain that in the
mcu only the gods are supposed to know that you
can use eternity this way do something like this
about the wish granting and only the gods are
supposed to know how to actually get to eternity
the secret of the bifrost they play it like thor
learns about this for the first time like oh
look it's the symbol of the bifrost but that's
mostly because thor is supposed to be kind of
dumb inside the mcu that's why in the movie they
say that he accidentally quote unquote enchants
mjolnir to protect jane foster and that's how she
winds up wielding it because he accidentally laid
an enchantment on it that was so powerful that
it was like odin's enchantment the way that gorr
learned about eternity during the movie is by
torturing other gods getting them to reveal all
the secrets of the godhead in omnipotent city this
is a big part of the comics gorr torturing other
gods for more information on his quest but in the
movie they kind of speed run over this part of the
plot like it's part of some of the deleted scenes
they're not very clear about this during the movie
but some of you probably picked up on this the
key to actually getting to eternity is using
the bifrost like they explained but it opens
a portal to the pocket dimension where actual
eternity exists even though it's meant to be the
consciousness of the entire universe the way you
actually would speak to eternity is inside this
separate pocket dimension space they call it an
alternate realm but that's the reason why the
bifrost is the key to getting there because the
bifrost opens portals between different places
different dimensions as well that's one of the
cool things about the bifrost that they get into
in the comics and they're a little bit more clear
about that they haven't really explained that much
in the movies like there's a big tutorial that
jane foster does early in the movie explaining
how the bifrost works like oh you open wormholes
between two points in space but you can actually
do that between different dimensions so like thor
can actually use the bifrost to get to valhalla
which is a different dimension like a different
state of existence where people's consciousness
exists separately from their bodies that's also
the key for how jane foster can come back
in future mcu projects you could also bring
back odin the other characters that are dead too
like the original version of loki they have a big
joke about that earlier in the film too like the
three different times that loki supposedly died
another good example of this the place where
eternity's actual consciousness exists is it's
kind of like the soul world of the soul gem like
this little pocket dimension where people go
after they snap the infinity gauntlet the place
where eternity exists where the soul world is
isn't just like a physical place like a planet
where you could fly to if you had a spaceship
you need a tool for traveling across different
dimensions the reason in the movie why zeus
isn't so worried about gorr killing all the
gods actually reaching eternity is because he
doesn't think that he's going to make it and it's
going to take him thousands of years to go around
doing it the slow style balancing the universe
one pantheon at a time also because while he's
doing that as thousands of years go by new gods
will be born replenishing their ranks that's the
whole reason why gorr stole the asgardian children
so that thor would bring him stormbreaker to bring
him the bifrost rescue them and give him the tool
that he needed to reach eternity so that he could
do it in one fell swoop so technically zeus was
right make another meme like terrible person
said something that you agree with thor played
right into gorr's hand but if gorr didn't need
the necrosaur to accomplish any of the things that
he did he just needed to be able to torture enough
gods to get the information to plan or trick thor
into giving him the bifrost thanos totally could
have done that if you remember the end of avengers
infinity war he was able to soak a full power
blast from stormbreaker and then a massive massive
physical blow to the body from the axe itself
and because stormbreaker didn't have the same
worthiness enchantment on it that mjolnir did
thanos could use it just like gorr did he even
used it against thor in avengers and game like
he literally picked up stormbreaker mid-flight
and tried to use it to kill thor but the main
reason why thanos didn't use eternity to do this
is mostly because he learned about the infinity
stones existence first and even though loki was
working for him is part of his plan to assemble
the infinity gauntlet and loki's one of the gods
technically and would know about eternity he'd
know this same legend if thor knew about eternity
loki's way smarter way more studious than thor he
would have known about it he would have also known
that the bifrost is the key but the whole thing is
that loki didn't tell thanos about eternity or the
way to use the bifrost to get there because he was
also using thanos just as much as thanos was using
him but the whole idea is that loki didn't really
care about thanos ever accomplishing his goal like
he didn't care about him assembling the infinity
gauntlet he never liked thanos he only made the
bargain with him initially out of a need for his
own survival in his desire for revenge against
thor odin in the nine realms just in general
but he didn't want to kill everyone in the nine
realms he just wanted them to acknowledge him
as superior even when he successfully enchanted
odin to make him forget who he was and took over
pretending to be him he just spent all that time
in asgard ruling lounging around watching plays
and building statues to himself so the main reason
why loki didn't reveal any of these secrets about
eternity to thanos was because they weren't to his
advantage and thor had not created stormbreaker
yet so thanos would have had to conquer asgard
first and use its bifrost which at the time that
loki made the bargain with thanos had just been
destroyed odin didn't rebuild their bifrost on
asgard till a little later in all he would have
had to do to stop thanos had thanos discovered the
secret to getting to eternity is simply destroy
the second by frost later and tell thor and anyone
else who were going to fight thanos not to use a
weapon that was enhanced with the bifrost like how
about you take these portal horses to thanos
instead of using the bifrost because that's
exactly what he needs so technically you have to
give credit to loki for keeping thanos away from
eternity in the mcu this whole time like loki
saves the day again he'd be so proud of himself
this is the original loki too that thanos wound up
killing in avengers infinity war who is currently
in valhalla so like jane foster now could go talk
to him if she wanted to and like i said if you do
want to get really technical about it and use
the comic book explainer thanos assembling the
infinity gauntlet made him almost more powerful
than eternity itself and eternity has a will
that's way stronger than the will of each of the
infinity stones so technically it was easier for
thanos to assemble the infinity stones than it
was to convince eternity to help him there's a
whole bunch of big cosmic concepts cosmic entities
that they introduced during the movie so i'll do
bonus videos for them too eventually i just
did a big post credit scene video all about
hercules and what happens to jane foster so i'll
put a link in the description below for that
congratulations king peter you're the giveaway
winner for the last big marvel video that i did
please email me on the about page of my channel so
i can get your contact details my full miss marvel
episode 6 finale video will post wednesday just
like normal everyone click here to learn about
all the thor love and thunder alternate endings
and deleted scenes and click here for my full
thor love and thunder breakdown for the
entire movie with easter eggs for everything
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!